hi in this video we'll talk about lactic
acid fermentation which is one of the an
Arabic fate of pyruvate so we have
already seen that glucose can be
converted to pyruvate by a 10-step
enzymatic process known as glycolysis
this pyruvate would eventually get into
the Krebs cycle and the products such as
nadh and fadh2 work like an electron
donor in the electron transport chain
and ultimately it would build up a
proton gradient which would be utilized
to generate the energy currency of the
cell that means the ATP glycolysis
itself can generate ATP as well so this
thing is the aerobic fate of the
ecologies because when oxygen is present
the electron transport chain can go on
because the terminal electron acceptor
is oxygen now imagine a situation where
oxygen is not present will come to a
conclusion why oxygen might be low or
why there is a hypoxic conditions we
will take real-life example but for now
let's imagine that oxygen is no in that
situation the etc' and the krebs cycle
might not be very efficient way to
generate ATP because the terminal
electron acceptor is not present in that
case what happens is pyruvate undergoes
are anaerobic fate which is the
fermentation it can generate ethanol or
it can generate lactic acid and
by-product of this process leaf will
that glycolysis pathway and as a result
glycolysis becomes the sole pathway for
generating energy for the cell so let's
try to put this reaction into context
okay but before that I want to tell you
why this kind of Lac
fermentation is important we know
glucose in a 10 step process give rise
to pyruvate and that's the outcome of
glycolysis that the product of
glycolysis right but imagine in this
particular pathway energy need to be
converted to NADH
so the glycolysis pathway need
steady-state supply of nad if nad is not
supplied then after a while glycolysis
pathway will be inhibited or it will run
down so there should be a way by which
nad can be replenished and under hypoxic
or low oxygen condition so pyruvate is
converted to lactate and this process is
a reduction process okay now coupled
with this reduction process which is
catalyzed by lactate dehydrogenase
something is oxidized and that is NADH
NADH in absence of oxygen get oxidized
to nad with the help of lactate
dehydrogenase as a result nad is
constantly supplied to the glycolysis
pathway and glycolysis pathway can go on
and produce ATP this is the sole goal of
the fermentation process the sole goal
of fermentation lactic fermentation
process is not to generate lactate
because eventually latin would be
converted to pyruvate but the sole goal
for fermentation of lactate is to
generate or regenerate NAD+ and this is
very important and the key enzyme that
helps in this process is lactate
dehydrogenase so let us talk about
lactate dehydrogenase in a bit
so the dehydrogenase name suggests the
hydrogenation is taking place the
hydrogenation from what the
hydrogenation of NADH so when NADH gets
the hydrogenated or otherwise oxidized
it forms nad Plus which can refill the
glycolysis now pyruvate is converted to
lactate
see the hydrogen in pink so the ketone
group is now converted to a secondary
alcohol group so it's a reduction so
pyruvate gets reduced to lactate whereas
NADH gets oxidized to nad these process
are coupled and triggered by lactate
dehydrogenase point we notate that
lactate dehydrogenase catalyzes reaction
is highly exergonic and the Delta G is
highly negative the overall equilibrium
of this reaction is strongly favored in
the forward direction now let us put
these concepts into a context of
physiological context let's say we are
performing power lifting or let's say
resistant training in the gym or let's
say we are sprinting so in very less
time we need a hell lot of energy in our
muscles yeah we have glucose but that
glucose is not sufficient even after
that there would be glucose coming from
glycogen breakdown but the muscle would
create too much of lactate because our
blood cannot efficiently supply oxygen
in that short span of time in our
muscles so there would be a anaerobic
situation in the muscle in that
situation et Cie would not be very
useful to give rise energy in this
situation glycolysis is the important
step so let's see what happens in the
muscle and the liver during this
anaerobic state or hypoxic state so
obviously in the muscle glucose need to
convert into pyruvate next a glycolysis
pathway and in this process ATP would be
generated which would film the muscle
for contraction now at the side product
nad is reduced to NADH as well pyruvate
would eventually get converted to left
it in the muscle which would refill that
energy demand for the glycolysis pathway
to occur in the muscle now lactate need
to be converted again so how that is
triggered so lactate is transported to
the liver now in the liver when the
lactate concentration is very high
lactate would weaken
to pyruvate with the same enzyme and
pyruvate would then get converted to
glucose with the help of the process
known as neo glucose Genesis so new
glucose Genesis tutoring enzymes are all
representing liver so pyruvate can
easily get converted to glucose
now this glucose could be resupplied to
the muscle and other tissues of the body
so this particular cycle is known as the
Cori cycle so in Cori cycle what we see
lactate is generated in the muscle which
gets converted to glucose again in the
liver and resupplied to the muscle so
overall in this video we looked at
lactic fermentation and the consequence
and the physiological importance of the
lactic fermentation and we also
discussed the Cori cycle in that context
so I hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give me a big thumbs up
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you